[Musique]
merci David Ross de nous accompagné
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu deesson membre du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain on
va commencer par l'actualité qui est
toujours du côté d'Israël et de ce
conflit avec le Hamas les combats qui
s'intensifient dans la bande de Gaza
Emmanuel Macron insiste sur la nécessité
d'un soutien humanitaire urgent il a la
bonne ligne le chef de l'État d'ord
merci pour votre invitation alors il
faut peut-être revenir quand même hélas
à cette journée du 7 octobre où les
terroristes du Hamas ont perpétré non
pas des actes de résistance non pas des
actes de guerre mais des crimes contre
l'humanité donc Israël ça a été dit
d'ailleurs par le Président de la
République a tout à fait le droit de se
défendre dans ce cadre-là ça leur pose
des questions d'ailleurs sur leur
sécurité intérieure et puis évidemment
les enjeux autour du hamast et de la
bande de Gaza en particulier et donc
effectivement il mènent des il mène des
opérations militaires avec forcément des
crimes qui sont liés à ça des crimes
plutôt de guerre ou des effets
collatéraux sur les les termes employés
il faut savoir que le Hamas utilise
beaucoup de réseaux qui partent de la
bande de Gaza des réseaux souterrain
avec de la population présente et savent
d'ailleurs très bien en jouer et donc il
faut trouver la bonne réponse entre une
action nécessaire pour éliminer ces
torises du du Hamas et en même temps
pouvoir protéger les populations civiles
donc ce qui est important pour moi c'est
qu'il y ait vraiment des conditions d'un
corridor sanitaire un cesser le feu
c'est difficile à dire je suis pas
spécialiste ça dépend un peu de des
situations donc il faut pas tomber non
plus dans le l'arrêt total des sont
menés par tsal mais en tout cas on voit
bien et ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs au
Dagestan montre bien qu'il a une tension
très forte donc il va falloir maintenant
que la communauté internationale puisse
définir les conditions à la fois des
meilleures conditions pour les
populations et aussi d'un terme à ce
conflit mais est-ce que est-ce qu'elle
le fait est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a
trouvé la bonne ligne il commence alors
le problème c'est que le il faut trouver
les bons interlocuteurs le Hamas qui
dans ses textes demande la destruction
d'Israël et des Juifs peut pas pas être
l'interlocuteur l'Égypte a essayé donc
il s'agit pas juste de dire on fait une
trêve il faut trouver les conditions
pour permettre d'assurer la sécurité à
la fois d'Israël et ensuite revenir au
processus de paix qui permettra de deux
états de vivre dans les conditions de
sécurité pour les deux quoi Emmanuel
Macron qui a proposé une coalition
antiamas est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
pour vous alors ça fait un peu d'honneur
de leçon on a été nous confrontter au
problème de daesh en Afrique pour moi la
priorité pour l'instant et j'ai aussi
une pensée évidemment pour les français
qui sont en qui sont pris en otage c'est
la libération des otages faut pas
oublier qu'il y a encore des civils qui
sont pris en otage donc la première
étape et je suis étonné dans les mots du
président de la République il pas cette
volonté internationale pour qu'il
demande préalable que les aotages soient
libérés elle pourrait d'ailleurs de
concert en disant si les aotages sont
libérés effectivement on fait une pause
et ensuite dit que c'est sa priorité le
chef de l'État la libération des oui
mais là on parle de d'in cesser le feu
entre guillemets il faut qu' un
préalable le préalable c'est vraiment la
libération des otages après une
coalition internationale c'est réunir
les pays qui jouent un rôle important
donc les États-Unis l'Égypte la position
de l'Arabie Saoudite on mettra pas
autour de la table Iran tant que dans sa
Constitution il précise aussi qu'il
veulent la destruction d'Israël mais ça
va je trouve que l'effet d'annonce est
un peu rapide au regarde de la situation
que l'on vit et Gérald Arman a annoncé
que 719 événements ou incidents
antisémites depuis le 7 octobre avait eu
lieu sur le territoire est-ce que
l'importation du conflit est là selon
vous oui tout à fait j'ai eu moi-même
dans ma commune des inscriptions qu'on a
dû effacer donc on sent qu'il y a une
toile de fond et des événements
d'agestan même si c'est pas en France le
le prouve donc il y a vraiment on est
sur une poudrière donc je comprends
aussi la volonté d'apaiser du président
de la République mais il faut aussi être
intraitable par rapport aux actes
antisémites qui se produisent en France
et qui ressortent assez
facilement il y a on a vu ce weekend
d'une manifestation propalestinienne qui
était interdite à Paris qui s'est quand
même tenu avec notamment des élus de
gauche est-ce que c'est leur place à
partir du moment où une manifestation
est interdite par le
Conseil
par gouver alors a eu lieu dansa vill à
Montpellier elle a été autorisée elle a
été autorisée dans le passé à Paris
c'est parce qu'on a estimé que les
conditions n'étaient pas réunies
justement de pas remettre de l'huile sur
le feu avec la tension qu'on voit
apparaître un petit peu en France et
donc si un élu de la République ne
respecte pas cette interdiction qui va
la respecter donc c'est aussi un signe
que l'on donne par rapport au
comportement des parlementaires c'était
pas leur place à ces parlementair de à
partir du moment où c'est sur une
manifestation qui est une situation bien
particulière il faut que chacun fasse
preuve de responsabilité il s'agit pas
d'interdire toutes les manifestations
pour l'État palestinien là ce sera autre
chose mais c'était pas ça dont il
s'agissait il y avait un risque de
trouble à l'ordre public c'est c'est ce
qu'a dit la justice on a notamment vu
Yannick jade Sandrine Rousseau ben je
vous invite à les inviter c'était pas
place on a compris votre position dans
une semaine on va parler d'un autre
sujet dans une semaine vous débuterez le
Sénat débutera l'examen du projet de loi
immigration pour trouver un compromis
avec les républicains et permettent le
vote du texte le gouvernement pourrait
revenir sur l'article 3 c'est l'article
qui vise a régularisé les travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension il pourrait
le sortir du texte le passé VI a une
circulaire qu'est-ce que vous en
penseriez bah écoutez c'est j'avais
envie de dire cet article 3 c'est un peu
la peau de chagrin de l'humanité de ce
gouvernement il y a une volonté de
durcir énormément les conditions liées à
l'immigration il y a une surenchère on
le voit même au Sénat où il y a eu des
prises de parole d'élus centristes qui
va dans ce sens et qui le confirme on
voit Elisabeth borne quiessit sur sa
droite de déborder Gérald larmanin donc
on on y perd son latin euh tous ceux qui
d'ailleurs au sein de la macronie qui
était plutôt ilelle centre gauche qui
l'avait soutenu ont perdu leur boussole
d'ailleurs s'ils veulent revenir le
Parti socialiste ils sont les bienvenus
mais plus sérieusement vous les appelez
cette aelle gauche de la Macron reven
sil se sent orphelin et qui voit que
dans les travaux que l'on mène ils sont
plus en phase avec nous la maison reste
ouverte donc voilà donc mais je suis
très inquiet on va voir la semaine qui
va se dérouler effectivement au Sénat et
les textes sont très très durs et
au-delà de cet article 3 il faut pas
oublier ce qui a fait la grandeur de la
France c'est cette capacité à intégrer
des gens qui venaient qui apportter
quelque chose au pays et cet article 3
il parle que des gens qui travaillent
pour la France mais il y a pas que ça il
y a les étudiants il y a les artistes et
il faudrait pas que en avec des
questions lié uniquement à la sécurité
on oublie tout le reste et on salisse
l'image de la France dans la durée ce
qui ce qui pourrait être le cas avec ce
Tex c'est ce que je trouve je vois c'est
un Tex qui pourrait salir l'image de la
France oui parce que la la question de
la sécurité qui est portée au niveau de
de l'ensemble de l'Europe ne peut pas
être stigmatisé que par la question de
l'immigration et par moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de revenir avec un chauffeur
G7 qui est là en France depuis 12 ans de
de nationalité algérienne qui n'arrive
pas à avoir un rendez-vous pour déposer
son dossier de naturalisation il est
intégré il est entraîneur de football au
Bourger pour des enfants et donc on est
en train en durcissant de retirer aussi
tous ceux qui étaient intégrés qui
veulent s'intégrer et qui ont participé
à construire la France et c'est un très
très mauvais signe qu'on donne à
l'international l'autre sujet c'est hier
Emmanuel Macron qui a annoncé via les
réseaux sociaux qu'il allait déposer un
projet de loi constitutionnel qu'il
allait le soumettre au Conseil d'État
cette semaine pour inscrire le droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution l'IVG
puisqu'il reprend le mot de liberté
c'est le mot qui a été voté par le Sénat
et non le mot droit à voter à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
êtes satisfait alors c'est une bonne
initiative parce que ça fait écho
effectivement au travaux des
parlementaires alors droit ou liberté ou
liberté d'avoir le droit bon ça on
pourra on pourrait s'amuser comme on
veut non ce qui est presque dommage
alors je je j'ai un peu la même phrase
que Marine Le Pen mais pour des raisons
différentes euh je trouve ça dommage
qu'on qu'on le met dans la Constitution
parce que si on le met dans la
constitution c'est parce qu'on sent
qu'il y a un danger on l'a vu aux
États-Unis on le sent dans certaines
discussions en France avec certains
partis notamment l'extrême droite et
donc c'est terrible d'en arriver là
parce que pour moi c'est une telle
évidence ce droit et cette liberté à
l'IVG que c'est on l'inscrit parce qu'on
sent qu'il y a des menaces donc c'est il
faut être vraiment très vigilant
là-dessus et donc mais vous pensez qu'il
y a des menaces parce que Marine Le Pen
a dit qu'il y a pas de menace que
personne ne remet en cause ce droit à
l'IVG écoutez avant ce qui s'est passé
aux États-Unis dans certains états on
pensait qu'il y aurait pas de menace
donc voilà donc on s'aperçoit que hélas
et le fait que les gens s'opposent à ça
euh qui peut le plus peut le moins donc
justement finalement sa réaction m'a
convaincu qu'il fallait effectivement
l'inscrire définitivement dans la
Constitution donc là-dessus bravo
Emmanuel Macron tout à fait on va parler
de Gabriel hatal vous êtes membre de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation au Sénat et c'est lesti un
ministre qui fait parler de lui en cette
rentrée c'est Gabriel à tal ses
chantiers sont nombreux mais a-t-il
amélioré la situation des professeurs et
des enseignants on va faire le point
avec notre journaliste Samia
Dechen
bonjour Samia bonjour Arian bonjour
David Ross et David Ross avant d'être
sénateur vous êtes aussi enseignant de
profession et depuis la rentrée il y a
un ministre qui fait beaucoup parler
Samia c'est Gabriel at oui on parle même
du Natal Mania depuis la rentrée Gabriel
hatal et partout et surtout sous le feu
des projecteurs il s'est d'abord imposer
sur des thèmes très médiatiques
l'interdiction de la BAA sa bataille
contre le harcèlement scolaire et puis
c'est l'actualité qu'il a un peu
propulsé d'elle-même encore un peu plus
sur le devant de la scène après
l'assassinat du professeur de lettres
Dominique Bernard dans un lycée d'aras
Gabriel est alimenté au créneau pour
défendre l'autorité de l'école il est vu
comme une étoile montante du camp
macroniste on parle même de lui pour la
présidentielle 2027 l'éducation
nationale c'est quand même le premier
budget de l'État et ça peut-être un vrai
tremplin dans une carrière politique
mais c'est aussi un poste à haut risque
samiia et d'autres avant lui on ont fait
les frais hein ah oui on pense bien sûr
à Jean-Michel Blanquer qui lui aussi
avait commencé très fort et on sait que
ça ne s'est pas très bien fini pour lui
pour réussir à l'éducation nationale il
ne faut pas séduire que l'opinion
publique il faut aussi se faire accepter
du corps enseignant et sur ce point-là
rien n'est encore écrit pour Gabriel
Atal regarder l'avertissement que lui
lançait fin août une responsable
syndicale du second degré Gabriel Attal
se dit très très audacieux en tout cas
vouloir faire preuve d'audace peut-être
que faire preuve d'audace en tout cas en
contre-point avec l'un de ses
prédécesseurs ça va être faire vraiment
vivre le dialogue social contrairement à
par exemple ce qu' avait pu faire
Jean-Michel Blanquer et ça ça va être un
élément un élément décisif parce que
Gabriel Atal arrive à un moment quand
même assez charnière pour l'éducation
nationale un moment où les personnels ne
vont pas bien à un moment où l'école ne
va pas bien et et on ce qu'on attend de
lui ce qu'on exige de lui c'est qu'il
puisse aussi entendre nos nos alertes
est-ce que le le vrai test pour
gabrielal ça va pas être le dialogue
social avec les enseignants parce que
là-dessus après tout il n'a pas encore
fait ses preuve oui alors d'ailleurs il
a été nommé il y a pas si longtemps que
ça on parlait de savoir s'il y avait
déjà des effets c'est très compliqué
c'est c'est une machine al je dirais pas
que c'est un mamouth mais c'est une
machine qui est assez assez lourde à
bouger70000 enseignants voilà qui est
assez lourde à bouger donc on peut pas
avir des résultats en 2 mois mais ce qui
est clair c'est que s'il intègre pas en
amont le dialogue social et de manière
plus générale le dialogue avec les
différents acteurs ça marchera pas alors
on vient de l'entendre à l'enseignement
c'est une profession qui va mal elle est
en pleine crise d'évocation avant la
rentrée Gabriel Atal avait promis qu'il
y aurait bien un professeur devant
chaque classe et il misait notamment sur
un pacte proposé aux enseignants une
meilleure rémunération des heures
supplémentaires pour ceux qui acceptent
de faire des remplacements de courte
durée on passe de 41 à 60 € brut de
l'heure d'après le ministre un
enseignant sur quatre aurait déjà
accepté sauf que visiblement ça ne
suffit pas à honorer sa promesse d'après
le SNES FSU le premier syndicat du
secondaire il manquait encore un
professeur dans 48 % des collèges et
lycées à la rentrée est-ce qu'il ne
sa'est pas avancer trop vite avec cette
promesse Gabriel Atal une promesse qui
risque de le suivre pendant longtemps ah
oui çaêtre le sparadra qui va qui va lui
coller la chaussure c'est moi en non par
exemple à arpageon il y a pas de prof de
physique ou de sciences des vies et et
et de la terre donc il y a des endroits
où il n'y a pas de professeur et je sais
pas comment CIT possible d'ailleurs en 2
mois de dire il y aurait un professeur
devant chaque élève de manière sûre euh
sachant que soit ils existaient déjà et
on comprendrait pas pourquoi ils étaient
pas en place ou soit il y a eu des
mesures qui permettent de faire des
hesupes ou de recruter mais ça il faut
un certain temps pour que ça soit
opérationnel donc c'était plus du
marketing de rentrée Samia l'autre
levier pour résoudre la crise de
l'attractivité c'est bien sûr
l'augmentation du salaire des
enseignants oui le gouvernement a sorti
le carnet de chèque hein cette année
Gabriel Atel a annoncé une augmentation
pour tous les professeurs entre 125 et
250 € nets par mois supplémentair selon
l'ancienneté le point d'indice a aussi
été revalorisé objectif garantir une
rémunération d'au moins 200000 € nets
par mois pour les professeurs en tout
début de carrière c'est la plus forte
augmentation salariale dans l'éducation
national depuis des décennies ass sur le
ministre même s'il a bien fallu
reconnaître que ça n'avait pas suffi à
rattraper entièrement leur perte de
pouvoir d'achat ces dernières années
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu' lui a rappelé un
sénateur du rassemblement national lors
de sa première audition au Sénat il
s'agit d'Emeric Durox qui était lui-même
professeur il revient sur l'augmentation
qu'il aurait eu qu'il s'apprêtait à
avoir juste avant d'être élu sénateur en
septembre dernier regardez j'allais
passer de 2200 € par mois à 2350 € ce
qui au bout de 10 ans d'expérience
surtout en région parenzienne vous en
conviendrait est assez peu et ceci
sans 13e mois sans ticket resto sans
médecine du travail sans comité
d'entreprise alors on l'a vu l'effort du
gouvernement il est conséquant mais
est-ce que ce sera suffisant est-ce que
il a fait assez pour rendre ce métier
plus attractif et notamment à travers la
question brûante du salaire alors c'est
toujours le le salaire c'est toujours le
la marotte puisque on avait même une
candidate à la présidentielle de mon
groupe politique qui qui prévoyait
d'augmenter encore plus fortement les
salaires pour moi le le sujet il n'est
pas que là c'estd qu'il est important et
ce qui a été fait est tout à fait est
tout à fait à à signaler mais c'est les
conditions de travail c'est justement
l'encadrement administratif c'est les
problèmes li de sécurité aux enseignants
c'est les effectifs dans les classe et
donc c'est pas tant ce salaire qui est
pour moi le le frein au voocation lié à
l'enseignement David Ramia on a parlé le
gros chantier auquel s'est attelé
Gabriel Atal en ce début de cette
rentrée c'est les questions de laïcité
il y a eu effectivement ce qui s'est
passé à haras on va y revenir mais la
première mesure qu'il a pris c'est
d'interdire la BAA Gabriel Atal il dit
aujourd'hui la BAA c'est une affaire
réglée vous êtes satisfait oui après moi
j'avais pas les chiffres mais je pense
que ça a été aussi mis énormément en
avant il avait raison il il fallait être
intransigent sur la question mais par
rapport aux autres enjeux dans l'école
c'était une manière de mettre aussi la
lumière sur quelque chose qui était pas
systématique qui était pas si développé
que ça ouais c'est pas une mesure
anti-islam comme certains lui ont dit
parce que que lui il dit je ne prends
aucune mesure anti-islam je prends des
mesures en faveur de la laïcité d'acc
avec tout à fait tout à fait en phase
avec ça il y a eu Sami en parlait
l'attaque terroriste qui a coûté la vie
à Dominique Bernard ce professeur de
français au lycée d'aras et après
l'attaque terroriste il y a eu une
minute dommage à Dominique Bernard à
Samuel pati au cours de laquelle il y a
eu des perturbations et Gabriel Atal a
annoncé que 183 élèves qui avaient eu
des comportements particulièrement
graves ce sont ces mots pendant cette
minute dommage ne ferait pas leur rentré
lundi prochain c'est une bonne mesure
qu'il a
prise encore il y a l'ffet d'annonce
effectivement il faut qu'il y ait de la
fermeté mais on ne voit pas en Toine le
fond où est le travail de sensibilité
d'éducation de pédagogie visà-vis de de
ces enfants qui ont eu un comportement
pour certains qui est vulgaire mais plus
sous forme de jeu ou de défi pour
d'autres où il peut y avoir des choses
plus profondes et donc ça nécessite
qu'un accompagnement justement pour
comprendre c'est pas en les excluant
fallait pas les exclure je dis pas ça je
dis que s'il y avait une exclusion il
faudrait qu'il des il y a à côté une
démarche qui permet de savoir ce qu'on
fait de ces enfantsl si c'est pour qu'il
restent chez eux et qui reviennent dans
un jour 3 semaines sans qu'il y eu aucun
travail avec eux ce sera le mal aura été
pire le remède aura été pire que le mal
donc pu a l'exclusion mais avec un
accomp avec un processus
d'accompagnement merci Samia à tout à
l'heure on va parler euh on va parler de
l'inscription divigée dans la
Constitution ce sera à suivre avec vous
dans le club on va continuer à parler de
l'actualité on va voir l'actualité dans
votre département de lesson maintenant
David Ros on retrouve Jacques Paquier
directeur de la rédaction du journal du
Grand Paris bonjour Jacques merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et on va
parler avec vous des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui auront lieu l'été
prochain et du bénéfice de CGO pour les
sones oui justement le bénéfice en
question si j'ose dire puisque on parle
de plus en plus de ces Jeux Olympiques
et et paralympiques mais on en parle
souvent euh pour parler de la scène
Saint-Denis alors je veux pas opposer
les départements entre eux mais Stéphan
Troussel le président de la scène
Saint-Denis aime a dire que c'est chez
lui que ça se passe et et c'est vrai que
que ce soit pour ce qui est de la
compétition elle-même au Stade de France
au centre aquatique olympique que
construit la métropole du Grand Paris
que ce soit pour l'héritage avec des
logements que ce soit pour le rattrapage
en équipement sportifs on sent que la
scène Saint-Denis va tirer euh son
épingle du jeu est-ce que monsieur le
sénateur vous pensez que lesesson euh
peut doit aussi euh s'actié pour pour
maximiser les retombées des JO dans ce
département alors c'est une très bonne
question al on on n' pas nous
d'installation prévu pour hélas pour
accueillir les les Jeux Olympiques euh
il y a 50 an niveline mais qui est qui
est pas en Nesson euh sur lequel il y
aura un certain nombre d'épreuves pour
moi ce qui est le plus important puisque
le président de la République veut aussi
qu'il ait une une nation sportive c'est
l'accompagnement pendant les Jio et
après avec un travail dans les écoles et
c'est ça qui est le plus important
c'estàd que il s'agit pas juste de
regarder le tableau des médailles et
ensuite de s'en laver les main il faut
revoir dans les pratiques sportives au
niveau de l'école à l'université où
souvent il y a pas beaucoup
d'installations pour pratiquer le sport
il faut profiter de ce cadre là pour
revoir comment on pratique le sport tout
au long de l'année dans nos différents
établissements donc tirer des bénéfice
pour l'après exactement est-ce que sur
le pendant vous êtes inquiet notamment
pour la sécurité de ces Jeux Olympiques
même si Gérald haranin se veut très
rassurant ben c'est une cérémonie
notamment d'ouverture qui est
extrêmement ambitieuse moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de poser la question parce
qu'on a eu Amélie oua cassera qu'on a
aussi auditionné sur notamment sur les
Jeux Olympiques sur les questions liées
à la sécurité et plus particulièrement
au potentiel attaque avec des drones moi
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui sur
lequel je je suis extrêmement attentif
interrogatif donc bon priori il y a pas
de raison de faire de procès avant
l'heure donc on va faire confiance aux
forces publ pour la bonne gestion de cet
événement donc oui pour maintenir la
cérémonie en extérieur où est-ce qu'il
faut la rapatrier dans un stade et faire
une cérémoniet les éléments qui assurent
la sécurité moi je fais confiance à ce
stade c'estans jeu de mot à ceux qui
organisent ces Jeux Olympiques Jacques
paquy on va parler d'un autre sujet avec
vous on va parler de l'Université Paris
sa clé puisque David Ross vous êtes
encore enseignant Labin oui absolument
vous êtes vous êtes docteur en physique
je crois monsieur rose et on s'est
toujours mettre de conférence à
l'Université justement Paris saclè si
mes informations sont bonnes et je
voulais en profiter de votre présence
justement pour vous demander ce que vous
quel premier bilan vous tirez de la la
fusion je crois que c'est une quinzaine
d'établissements qui sont sont réunis au
sein de l'Union de l'Université Paris
saccly avec un un bénéfice qui s'est vu
dans le classement de shanghï alors je
voulais savoir vous qui êtes
scientifique ce que vous en pensez alors
ça été un grand mouvement depuis
quasiment effectivement 10 ans de créer
cette grande université Paris sa cl
alors au départ l'ambition c'était
d'aller avec l'intégration de l'École
polytechnique finalement on est arrivé
un petit peu à moitié du chemin puisque
il y a eu l'Institut polytechnique de
Paris qui a été créé l'autre parti
l'autre pendant entre guillemets
universitaire mais le fait de fusionner
c'est pas pour faire un gros machin
comme on dit hein ça a été aussi pour
que les scientifiques des différents
organismes apprennent à discuter
ensemble à travailler à définir un
projet en commun et ça c'est une belle
réussite alors après il reste à intégrer
les étudiants à la vie parce que c'est
un grand campus qui se construit
notamment sur le plateau de sa clé et
donc il a un grand nombre
d'installations encore à à finaliser
dont des installations sportives et puis
il y a la question des financements
parce que le fait de regrouper tout ça
fait que dans la pratique un certain
nombre d'équipes de recherche on
l'impression que alors qu'avant elle
pouvait postuler à différents appels
d'offre en venant de différents
organismes le fait d'être du même
organisme a l'air de les freiner dans
l'obtention d'un certain nombre de
subventions et l'État a été averti de ce
phénomène là et donc j'espère qu'il y
aura des mécanismes qui permett de
réguler tout
ça merci d' allez-y d'un mot j'ai encore
j'ai encore si j'ai encore une minute je
voulais vous demander justement la
l'état d'avancement du projet lui-même
d'urbanisme parce que c'est aussi un
Paris de faire venir les étudiants de
faire venir les familles sur un plateau
qui est encore très largement agricole
alors on a réussi sur l'arrivé parce
qu'on voit un grand nombre d'étudiants
qui augmente chaque année avec notamment
moi je vais de temps en temps à la
cafette du cru pour les étudiants on
entend maintenant parler espagnol
italien anglais bien sûr on est un peu
en retard dans les transports on attend
la ligne 18 et donc c'est vrai que le
matin c'est un petit peu saturé pour se
rendre sur le site merci Jacques Paquier
merci d'avoir été avec nous on regarde
la Une du journal du Grand Paris cette
semaine Jeux Olympiques et paralympique
visite préfectorale sur plusieurs sites
d'entraînement c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Jacques d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin on va terminer en
en disant quelques mots du Parti
socialiste David Ros puisque le plus
beau des
partis on imagine que que c'est ce que
vous pensez un un mot sur le moratoire
qui a été voté par la majorité du Parti
socialiste moratoire sur l'anub c'est un
moratoire qui va durer jusqu'à quand je
sais pas mais effectivement on va pas
pouvoir le faire durer très longtemps il
va falloir un moment que LFI se
positionne par rapport à un certain
nombre maintenant de de lignes qui ont
été franchies et soit ils acceptent
qu'il y a eu des erreurs de commise et
je reviens sur cette journée vraiment du
du du 7 octobre pour moi il y a des
événements qui sont des moments de
vérité voilà et ce qui s'est passé en
Israël fait partie d'un de ces moments
de vérité la relation qu'à Luc Mélenchon
qui venait de l'esson d'ailleurs par
rapport à la République et aussi un
autre moment de vérité donc il va
falloir que ça ce soit tranché parce que
sinon ce sera pas possible de faire ce
rassemblement sur la même base que ce
que nous avions essayé de réaliser donc
vous vous attendez quoi précisément de
la France insoumise Ben qui précise leur
position par rapport à un certain nombre
de questions sur sur la République et et
notamment pour moi il y a maintenant un
préalable ils peuvent pas considérer que
ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre n'était
pas une attaque de terroriste ça il faut
que ce mot soit dit parce que Manuel
bonpard il a redit hier qu'il avaient
jamais jamais été ambigu qu'ils ont
condamné les attaques du Hamas qu'ils
ont dit que c'était des crimes de guerre
alors c'est plus que des crimes de
guerre c'est vraiment des crimes contre
l'humanité mais je pense qu'une grande
partie d' Lafi est peut-être sur cette
position là mais ils ont un leader qui
lui fait beaucoup trop parler de lui
dans un sens qui est un peu divergent de
celui-là et Emmanuel bonpard qui est le
chef maintenant de la France insoumise
il dit qu'il comprend pas la position du
Parti socialiste il dit j'ai pas compris
j'ai écrit à Olivier fort pour avoir des
explication il m'a pas répondu bah s'il
a pas compris et il faud peut-être qu'
qu'il relise tout ce que on a a pu dire
sur le sujet parce que les choses sont
relativement claires pourtant donc
est-ce que la rupture est irréversible
ah vous savez dans la vie je sais pas si
l'irréversibilité en plus en physique
c'est aussi un vrai sujet mais en tout
cas pour l'instant c'est sûr que on n
pas estce qu' un moment il va falloir
rompre est-ce qu'il va falloir dire
voilà on peut plus faire alliance avec
la France insoumise est-ce que le
moratoire c'est pas une sorte de en même
temps finalement et ça c'est un peu ça
c'est c'est du c'est un peu dur en même
temps et ça peut pas durer éternellement
le en même temps donc on verra le moment
venu mais pour moi le plus important
c'est le rassemblement des forces de
gauche sur un projet nous on estime
maintenant que avec un certain nombre
d'acteurs on le voit au Sénat on est
d'accord sur un grand nombre de
positionitions avec le Parti communiste
avec les vers si des forces d' Lafi se
sentent nous rejoindre sur cette base là
peut-être qu'on va procéder autrement
parce que le cas de l'anups n'a plus de
sens pour moi à l'heure où je donc la
nupes est finie mais la nupes en fait
c'est un accord électoral LFI a déposé
la marque nupes donc pour moi c'est un
non sujet c'est c'est LFI qui a voulu
s'approprier ce rassemblement parce
qu'ils étaient les leaders après le
second tour de la présidence on est
rentré dans une autre séquence et on
verra une autre séquence c'est une union
de la gauche s- Jean-Luc Mélenchon ben
en tout cas Jean-Luc Mélenchon je vois
pas comment il avait la capacité d'être
le rassembleur il a montré qu'il était
le diviseur donc il faut passer à autre
chose merci David Ross merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure